[Musique]
notre invité politique aujourd'hui c'est
donc Annie jeunevard bonjour bonjour
vous êtes députés les républicains du
Doux secrétaire général du parti les
républicains nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régional qui
est représenté aujourd'hui par Julien
Lescuyer journaliste éditorialiste à la
voie du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
Alexandre bonjour madame bonjour on va
évidemment commencer cette interview par
la colère agricole qui se durcit partout
dans le pays on a vu ces images de
déversement de lisier de pneus brûlé
devant la préfecture d'agin également du
déversement de lisier devant la
permanence parlementaire d'une députée
insoumise de la Creuse les blocages
routiers s'intensifient partout dans le
pays est-ce qu'un on a même vu un
drapeau européen brûlé hein c'est un
symbole fort est-ce qu'à un moment le
ministre de l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin
doit demander au force de l'ordre
d'intervenir et de lever ses blocages
pour l'ordre public alors évidemment si
euh des fait graves se produisait il
faut une intervention de la force
publique mais le message est-ce qu'il se
produis selon vous aujourd'hui est-ce
que ces faits sont graves écoutez euh il
faut que les paysans puissent exprimer
légitimement leur colère sans que des
débordements trop graves ne soient
aperçus donc c'est un équilibre subtil
si vous contraignez trop vous allez
augmenter la colère si vous ne primimz
pas des faits
graves c'est insupportable au regard du
de de du respect de l'ordre public donc
c'est dans cet équilibre compliqué qu'il
faut que cet équilibre madame jeevard on
n pas l'impression que ce soit le même
sens quand il s'agit de manifestation
écologiste Yan jado lui-même a pointé du
doigt de poids de de mesure est-ce que
concrètement la colère et les violences
sont admissible quand on est paysan mais
pas quand on défend l'cologie pas mais
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que les
écolos se sont livrés à des actes graves
contre les policiers vous le savez bien
je n'ai pas vu que les paysans s'en
soient pris physiquement au policier ça
c'est la première remarque la deuxième
remarque que je voudrais faire c'est que
la colère paysane elle est aussi le fait
d'une révolte contre les normes imposées
par notamment par les Amis de des écolos
monsieur monsieur campfin avant d'être
un député européen Renaissance il était
et la colère des paysans c'est aussi à
l'égard des écolos on va en parler juste
sur cette question d'ordre publi pour
l'instant une intervention des forces de
l'ordre n'est pas souitable ça pourrait
mettre de l'huile sur le feu bah il faut
veiller à ce que ça ne mette pas d'huile
sur le feu et mais de leur côté les
paysans doivent aussi encadrer les
manifestations faire preuve de
responsabilité bien sûr et d'ailleurs
c'est le discours que j'ai plutôt
entendu chez les responsables agricoles
alors le gouvernement devrait faire des
annonces rapidement pour répondre à
cette colère des agriculteurs on parle
d'une accélération de la simplification
des normes d'une meilleure application
de la loi égalim pour que les
agriculteurs aient un revenu digne dans
les négociations commercial notamment
avec l'industrie est-ce que ce serait
des mesures suffisantes selon vous quand
vous écoutez les agriculteurs ils sont
nombreux dans ma circonscription et je
les fréquente régulièrement et j'ai pour
eux énormément d'admiration et de
considération pour le travail qu'il
qu'il font et qui n'est pas reconnu à sa
juste valeur on oublie trop souvent à
quel point ils sont essentiels pour nous
nourrir d'abord pour entretenir nos
paysages et
puis assurer à la France un rang qu'elle
ne cesse d'ailleurs de de perdre au fil
des politiques publiques je crois que
les paysans demandent trois choses ils
demandent d'abord un revenu il n'est pas
normal que des gens qui travaillent 60
70h 80h par semaine et des salaires des
revenus aussi faibles c'est indigne
c'est indécent c'est insupportable donc
ça c'est la loi égalim qui est à
remettre en cause oui la loi égalime 1
la loi égalime 2 n'a pas apporté les
fruits qu'on espérait en terme de
revenus donc faut être plus ferm avec
les industriels par exemple le imposer
des prix planchés pour nos agriculteurs
alors moi je pense que les industriels
sont très durs dans les négociations t
tous les paysans tous les producteurs
vous vous le diront clairement depuis
des années en France on a choisi le
distributeur au détriment du le
consommateur au détriment du producteur
il faut là aussi rétablir une forme
d'équilibre alors je sais bien que se
pose la question de des revenus des
Français du pouvoir d'achat c'est c'est
c'est ça qui rend le débat extrêmement
compliqué parce que si vous payez à leur
juste prix les
produits évidemment ça va compliquer la
vie des consommateurs modestes mais
est-ce qu'il faut pas dire aussi la
vérité aux Français en disant que si si
vous voulez faire survivre voir survivre
la l'agriculture française il faudra
payer plus bien sûr ça suppose de
reconsidérer les modes de de
consommation sans aucun doute donc des
revenus la deuxième chose qu'il demande
c'est de la considération et il y a un
sondage qui vient de sortir qui me
réjouit personnellement c'est le fait
que les Français dans leur immense
majorité mais
écrasante 90 % quasiment soutiennent les
revendications des agriculteurs c'est
très réjouissant parce que quand on
entend certains on a l'impression que
les agriculteurs sont accusés de tous
les mots euh d'être despollueurs de
maltraiter leurs animaux madame Genevard
ça veut dire qu'amour français sont
beaucoup plus y a l'amour il y a de
l'amour pour les pour les pour les
paysans pour les agriculteurs ça il y a
pas de souci ce qu' vous demande c'est
des preuves d'amour qu'est-ce que vous
vous leur apportez comme preuve d'amour
alors nous et la troisème chose ce sont
les normes je voudrais finir de dérouler
les trois
points un revenu considérationation et
alors très clairement très clairement il
faut interdire la surtransposition la
France veut laver plus blanc que blanc
la l'Europe édicte des normes la France
presque systématiquement les
surtranspose et ça fait des années qu'on
le dénonce et ça fait des années qu'on
continue de surtransposer on arrête
surtrposition ça ça n'est pas possible
c'est pas c'est pas la faute de l'Europe
par exemple comme le dit Jordan Bardella
c'est la faute des gouvernements
français qui vont au-delà des normes
euré alors il y a une responsabilité
européenne vous savez que les
dispositions farm tout for c'est la
fourche à la fourchette qui vise à
diminuer les surfaces surfaces agricoles
la restauration de la nature enfin
toutes ces dispositions européennes le
pacte vert nous on s'est battu contre ça
avec acharnement et et François Xavier
béami et an Sander ont été à la manœuvre
pour se battre contre ses dispositions
c'est c'est 6 derniers mois on rappelle
que le pacte vert est quand même défendu
par une Commission européenne qui est à
droite
oui mais euh moi je vous parle de la
position de la France à l'eope notre
délégation française elle s'est inscrite
en faux et et voilà
donc se battre contre les normes se
battre pour moins de charge nous nous
préconisons la suppression des charges
sociales sur les contrat court ce qui
est fait sur le gasoil non routier il y
a une hausse de taxesous nous savions
nous savions que ça allait coincer parce
que objectivement ça diminue fortement
le reste à vivre le revenu des
agriculteurs donc et puis
il faut l'abandonner cette hausse de
taxes sur le gazol rou je pense moi je
pense qu'il faut enfin nous pensons
qu'il faut l'abandonner en effet et puis
de façon générale il faut lutter contre
ce discours qui met en accusation en
permanence les agriculteurs et qui qui
qui complique terriblement leur est-ce
qu'il faut réformer l'administration on
sait que les les agriculteurs ont une
dent particulière contre la dttm
direction départementale des territoires
et de la mer il manifeste devant
l'Office de la biodiversité aussi est
pointé du du doigt est-ce qu'il faut
réformer moi je pense qu'il faut
réformer les les comportements
administratifs
aujourd'hui l'agriculture n'échappe pas
à la bureaucratisation de notre pays qui
devient démentes on l'observe à tout
niveaux on sait ce que ça coûte en terme
d'efficacité à l'hôpital mais c'est la
même chose pour les agriculteurs il ils
disent qu'ils ne peuvent plus supporter
le la surcharge de administratif qui
leur est imposé Annie jeev on va parl de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
puisque hier soir l'Assemblée nationale
a voté favorablement à l'introduction
dans dans la constitution de la liberté
garantie pour les femmes de recourir à
une IVG sur les 62 députés les
républicains 56 députés étaient absents
hier quatre ont voté contre cette mesure
proivg deux pour dont Aurélien Pradier
Annie jeunevard vous vous étiez absente
pourquoi n'avoir pas pris part à un vote
aussi important alors d'une part j'étais
présente jusqu'à 20h mais au moment du
vote mais mais et donc il y a eu des
votes il y a eu des votes sur l'article
unique donc il y a eu des votes auquels
j'ai
participé je n'ai je suis je ne suis par
venu à la reprise parce que je parce que
je venais chez vous ce matin et qu'il
fallait un peu les choses donc on peut
pas être au Fouré au moulinuraé votre
mais mais mais on aura un vote solennel
mardi donc il y aura bien un vote où là
les députés seront nombreux vous savez
quand le texte est en discussion il y a
pas tous les députés ne sont pas là et
vous auriez voté quoi madame je moi
j'aurais voté contre non pas contre
l'IVG parce que je voudrais rappeler
quand même que le débat ça n'est pas
pour ou contre l'IVG je voudrais le dire
très clairement aux téléspectateurs
l'IVG n'est pas remise en cause la
question est de savoir si on l' inscrit
dans la Constitution est-ce qu'il faut
constitutionnaliser l'IVG pour renforcer
ce droit pour renforcer ce droit je n'ai
pas vu que depuis que ce droit a été
voter il est été remis en cause à un
quelconque moment au Parlement au
contraire chaque fois que l'IVG a été
évoqué au Parlement ça a toujours été
pour en élargir l'application 10 à 12
semaines 12 à 14 semaines euh et vous
avez vu les attaques même au sein de de
l'Europe qui ont pu survenir sur ce sur
ce droit on l'a vu en Pologne ex mais la
France n'est pas la Pologne la France
n'est pas les
États-Unis il y a il y a une sorte
d'affolement parce que d'autres pays
remettraient en cause chez nous le le le
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse a
une histoire singulière c'est une
française qui a porté cette loi dans des
condition bien particulière d'ailleurs
Simon veale était contre sa
constitutionnalisation et elle n'a
jamais dans son discours ni dans le
texte parler de droit à elle dit elle et
là on parle de liberté garantie pour
vous c'est la même chose la liberté
garantie le mot garantie évidemment
s'apparente à une forme de droit a et
c'est la dessus alors le blocage porte
sur deux points à la fois sur la
formulation liberté garantie ça veut
dire droit à de notre point de vue et
puis sur le fait même de
constitutionnaliser et de ce point de
vue-là la remarque de Gérard larch est
intéressante quand il dit la
Constitution qui est le la loi
fondamentale n'a pas vocation à être une
énumération du droit sociétaux donc ça
c'est une réflexion intéressante et je
pense qu'elle mérite d'être d'être
vraiment prise en compte justement vous
vous dites vous êtes contre cette
constitutionnalisation tout comme le
président Jard Larcher qui a exprimé
cette semaine son opposition à cette
réforme constitutionnelle qui je le
rappelle a besoin des voix de la
majorité du Sénat pour d'abord être
adopté dans des termes identiques est-ce
que les républicains ne sont pas en
train de tomber dans un piège politique
d'Emmanuel Macron et c'està-dire
d'apparaître comme un parti rétrograde
sur les droits des femmes mais est-ce
que est-ce que dans cette affaire nous
revenons sur les droits des femmes je ne
crois pas peut pas on peut pas
considérer que c'estit une régression
puisque personne ne songe à remettre en
cause un droit qui est désormais
complètement acquis en France et que
personne sérieusement n'a jamais cherché
à remettre en cause qui est des
opposants à l'ivivg on est dans un pays
démocratique où l'expression libre est
possible en la matière mais c'est euh
c'est pas parce qu'il existe des
mouvements antiivg que l'IVG est remise
en cause dans notutrre pays ça n'est pas
le cas c'est pas une régression des
droit c'est une question de droit est-ce
qu'il faut l'inscrire ou pas dans la
Constitution c'est ça la question qui
est posée donc le piège politique oui
certainement Emmanuel Macron ne rate
jamais une occasion d'essayer de coincer
la droite mais il y a là un combat de de
de de conviction et un combat aussi de
liberté d'expression est-ce qu'on peut
librement dire dans notre pays que la
constitutionnalisation juste une
dernière petite question là-dessus mais
le député du du Lot Oren pradiier hier à
parlé de d'ystérisation des des des
débats en accusant certaines députés de
la de de la gauche euh ça a été jugé
scandaleux par ces ces mêmes députés
vous comprenez leur leur ressentiment
par rapport à ça bah le mot hisérisation
est pour certaines femmes très connotées
l'étymologie d'hystérisation ça vient de
uérus donc fait une façon de renvoyer
les femmes à leur à leur utérus c'est ça
qu'on dit les les les députés féministes
hier honnêtement c'était pas du tout le
propos de d'Aurélien Prad le terme
mystérisé aujourd'hui n'a plus le sens
originel qu'on lui connaissait ce que je
voudrais dire pour imigration pour
terminer c'est que euh
constitutionnaliser un droit que
personne ne conteste et refuser de
modifier la Constitution sur la question
migratoire dont on va parler euh VO
c'est aussi c'est aussi une des raisons
pour lesquelles effectivement nous ne
voulons pas pour certains d'entre nous
tomber dans ce dans dans ce piège et
bien justement on va continuer à parler
de la Constitution puisque aujourd'hui
cet après-midi le Conseil
constitutionnel va rendre son avis sur
la loi immigration il pourrait censurer
certaines mesures qui ont été ajoutées
au texte par les républicains comme le
durcissement de l'accès aux aides social
pour les étrangers durcissement
durcissement de l'accès également au
regroupement familial si vos mesures
sont censurées ce sera un échec pour les
LR ce sera un échec pour les Français
déjà parce que les Français plébiscitent
largement les mesure de la loi
immigration qui a été votée grâce aux
apports de la droite et on verra ce que
dit le Conseil constitutionnel mais nous
nous contestons le fait que des mesures
ne soient pas constitutionnelles qu'il y
ait des cavaliers législatif quasiment
toutes les mesures sur lesquelles
c'estàdire des mesures hors sujet par
rapport au texte voilà un cavalier
législatif c'est un un une disposition
qui est sans rapport avec le texte
toutes les mesures que nous avons fait
adopter ont une relation avec la
question de l'immigration et de
l'intégration qu'il s'agisse du délit de
séjour irrégulier qu'il s'agisse du
durcissement des conditions d'accès à la
nationalité qu'il s'agisse du titre de
séjour étranger malade qu'il s'agisse de
l'absence d'automaticité d'acquisition
de la nationalité française pour les
jeunes qui devront en faire la demande
donc toutes ces mesures elles ont un
rapport et plus encore
elles ont
été adoptées dans le passé dans le passé
elles ont été jugés constitutionnel la
gauche les a retiré du droit par exemple
le délit de séjour irrégulier il a été
jugé conforme à la Constitution en 2011
ça c'est le mémoire que vous avez déposé
auprès de du Conseil constitutionnel av
déposé un mémoire auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel un mémoire très précis
pour dire de notre point de vue ces
mesures ne sont pas
antionstitutionnell et puis sur les
dépenses les les prestations sociales
non contributives en droit aujourd'hui
il existe une disposition qui fait que
le RSA ne peut pas être accordé à
quelqu'un sur le minimum retraite aussi
sur le minimum retraite qui n'a pas fait
état d'une d'un séjour régulier en
France depuis 5 ans ça existe déjà dans
le droit ça existe mais en effet il y a
une menace sur 30 à 40 articles du du du
projet de loi qui pourrait faire l'objet
d'une censure d'une censure partielle ou
bien d'êt considéré comme des des des
cavaliers législatifs est-ce que s'il y
avait une une partie des articles qui
n'étaient pas retenus par le Conseil
constitutionnel il y aurait pas un
problème de crédibilité politique
vis-à-vis de de vous étant donné que
vous avez manifestement défendu des
articles qui étaient antionstitutionnels
alors moi je voudrais dire que ça c'est
le discours de la majorité ça c'est le
discours de la majorité qui dit voyez
ils sont pas sérieux ils ont fait voter
ils nous ont obligé à adopter des
mesures dont ils savaient qu'elles
n'étaiit pas constitutionnelle
d'ailleurs le gouvernement attend la
censure de ces mesures donc ça montre
bien le double discours de la majorité
sur ce sujet je viens de de de de vous
expliquer pourquoi toutes les mesures
que dont le gouvernement espère qu'elles
soit retoqué ont été en son temps adopté
et validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel elles étaient
constitutionnels et aujourd'hui elle ne
le serait plus donc ça c'est quand même
un problème mais surtout le grand
perdant dans cette affaire ce ne serait
pas la droite le grand gagnant ne serait
pas la majorité les perdants ce seraient
les Français ça veut dire que
définitivement la France ne peut pas
recouvrer sa souveraineté en matière
migratoire ça c'est extrêmement grave et
pour ça veut dire très concrètement
madameev que si s' il y a une censure
partielle encore une fois du du texte
est-ce que vous relancerez le débat sur
un une modification de la Constitution
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr mais
vous n'avez pas de majorité pour voter
cette réforme de la
Constitution c'est un vux pieux vous
n'avez absolument pas les moyens de
porter cette réforme de la Constitution
je pense pense très clairement que alors
d'abord la situation à l'Assemblée au
Sénat n'est pas la même est-ce qu'au
Sénat il peut y avoir des avancées en
matière de révision de la Constitution
sur ces questions c'est à discuter euh
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que à
force d'ignorer le sentiment des
Français les Français disent dans toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion qu'il faut
absolument que la France retrouve la
maîtrise en matière d'immigration soit
la majorité choisit de dire très bien le
Conseil constitutionnel a censuré on est
tranquille la droite a échoué nous
finalement notre double langage à payer
et puis qu'importe l'opinion des
Français ça ça un prix c'est un coût et
en 2027 on verra le le coût politique de
ce renoncement et de cette lâcheté soit
courageusement on dit il y a un problème
le cadre constitutionnel actuel ne le ne
permet pas de le traité et on se met
autour de la table et on réfléchit à la
façon de de faire bouger les lignes en
la matière dernière question sociale sur
cette loi immigration selon le collectif
nos services publics qui est un
collectif d'agents public de
fonctionnaires et bien si vos mesures
sont appliquées en l'état au moins 11000
foyers en France vont voir leur revenus
baisser et le taux d'enfants étrangers
en grande pauvreté et bien passerait de
27 % à 53 % est-ce que on n'est pas dans
une mesure dans des mesures antisociales
écoutez ça je sais pas je je découvre
ces chiffres il demande vraiment être
expertisé ce que je sais c'est que cette
question migratoire elle rétablit très
fortement un clivage gauche droite la
gauche est absolument elle est
globalement euh nos bordur enfin pas
plus de frontière on accepte on on on
prend en charge la France est un pays
qui peut qui a les moyens de
d'accueillir tout le monde
euh et et voilà donc la droite dit il y
a un problème de cohésion sociale il y a
un problème de soutenabilité financière
il y a un problème de souveraineté donc
voilà il y a le Disc et donc on
appauvrit les familles étrangères mais
non il s'agit pas d'appauvrir la
conséquence concrète ce sera ça mais
pourquoi dites-vous ça bah si on coupe
certaines si on cou si on coupe
certaines prestations sociales pendant
une certaine durée forcément il y aura
un a un appauvrissement non on ne coupe
pas certaines prestations on dit aux non
mais on dit aux étrangers qui veulent
venir dans notre pays parce que la loi
n'est pas
rétroactive les prestations sociales non
contributives elles s'appliqueront au
aux aux étrangers qui arrivriverait dans
notre pays euh donc il faut faut pas
tout mélanger lorsqu'un étranger choisit
de venir sur notre sol et bien il sait
que ce sera à certaines conditions voilà
il s'agit pas du jour au lendemain de
priver de prestation sociale les
familles qui seraient déjà dans notre
pays mais qui vont arriver vous savez
c'est intéressant de voir ce qui se
passe au Danemark moi j'y suis allé et
bien au Danemark les Danois disent aux
étrangers on vous préviens si vous venez
dans notre pays vous vous n'aurez pas
droit à
tout vous devez demander l'autorisation
de venir sur notre sol et si ça n'est
pas le cas vous n'aurez
droit gouvernement de
gauche et l'extrême droite est réduite à
poau de chagrin parce que il y a une
fermeté an je on va finir par une
question politique notamment sur les
élections PN Julien oui parce que votre
candidat François Xavier béami stagne à
8 % dans le dernier sondage Opinion we
Solis pour les écho en 4e position excho
avec la France insoumise est-ce qu'il y
a
péril bon la campagne n'a pas commencé
François Xavier bami a fait un travail
extraordinaire à l'Europe il a
franchement d'ailleurs il est
extrêmement respecté à la tête d'une
petite délégation parce que nous sommes
peu nombreux il a réussi à emporter des
arbitrages que personne ne pensait
possible d'obtenir donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a énormément travaillé il est
l'incarnation de ces élus qu'on voudrait
voir plus nombreux qui dès lors qu'ils
ont reçu la confiance des électeurs
travaill on peut être respecté et
inaudible madame Genevard qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour que justement
françoisavier bami émerge de la campagne
parce que et bien parce que la campagne
n'a pas commencé elle a commencé chez or
elle a
commencéid elle commence à peine bah
écoutez
là il faut que les Français il faut
arriver à faire faire il y a pas un
problème de récit madame jeunevard pour
s'identifier le réit n'a pas encore
commencé la campagne n'a pas encore
commencé donc moi je fais confiance aux
Français ils vont entendre des débats
ils vont voir qui est sérieux qui est
dans l'incantation politique
comme Jordane Bardella qui est dans le
double discours malhonnêtein à Paris on
soutient les agriculteurs mais à
Bruxelles on vote toutes les mesures qui
vont les contraintre ça c'est
Renaissance c'est la majorité donc moi
je compte beaucoup sur ces débats pour
montrer aux français où est le sérieux
où est le travaille où est la l'esprit
de responsabilité voilà donc la campagne
elle va commencer et puis vous savez je
me méfie toujours des
prédictions
pessimiste et et les sondages voilà une
campagne c'est une conviction c'est une
incarnation c'est un projet et c'est ce
à quoi on va s'atteler merci beaucoup
Annie jeunevard d'avoir été notre invité
politique du jour merci Julien d'être
venu aujourd'hui dans notre émission on
va regarder la Une du journal La Voix du
Nord qui est consacré à la colère
agricole avec ce titre la colère gagne
du terrain les blocages se multiplient
tout de suite c'est le club des
territoires